chests bursting babies shovels to the
face and the scariest thing of all
Lamaze class into the dark season two's
delivered makes me never want to have a
baby
bleeds we can kill it in this video
we're gonna take a deep dive into the
ending explaining some of its hidden
details and the significance of what our
main character ended up calling her baby
so ignore all calls from your baby daddy
because here we go delivered tells the
story of Valerie coats a pregnant
counselor from Chicago who's moved to
Colorado to escape her ex Riley while
her husband Tom is excited to be
starting this new chapter of their life
Valerie isn't the thought of having a
child scares her she's not ready to be a
mom she hates being sick all the time
continually puts off building their
baby's crib and not to mention she knows
that Tom isn't the real father Reilly is
if it were up to Val she probably
wouldn't want this baby at all which is
why she's contrasted with the antagonist
of the film Jenny and yes that's the
same actress who played Deb in Napoleon
Dynamite Jenny so wants a child that she
fakes being pregnant to attend Lamaze
classes to scope out her victims as
we'll find out later Jenny keeps a
record of her previous victims all
pregnant women
she has their cars locked up in her barn
and profiles of their personality traits
here we can see Valerie's no family
naive unhappy and not ready to be a mom
if Valerie is going to grow as a
character and embrace the child she
eventually gives birth to she's gonna
have to realize the importance of life
which is why she ends up naming her
daughter Ava which is derived from Latin
and Hebrew for life while Val struggles
with the idea of becoming a mother there
is nothing Jenny wants more I know this
sounds silly but
it feels like it's the only thing that
I've ever wanted
jenny is obsessed with having a child
she refers to vowels as her own and even
recreates childbirth with a doll so she
invites Val and Tom up to her secluded
home where she drugs Valerie and
brutally murders Tom with an axe this
obsession was brought upon by the trauma
of her past near the end of the film we
learned that Jenny had abusive parents
who when they found out she was pregnant
cut out her baby she ended up killing
her parents and losing the child and now
cuts out babies from other woman's so
that she can have her own it's implied
that her parents procedure on her made
it so that she can't have her own child
hence her needing to find other means of
obtaining one Jenny's previous attempts
at capturing a pregnant mother so she
can have their child that didn't go over
so well don't want you to worry about
last time this time everything is gonna
be perfect she's been performing botched
c-sections but feels that this time with
Val will be different it's going to work
at the beginning of the film she
mentions that she's a pediatric nurse
but later Val finds this convenient box
of exposition which shows us that she
was just an office manager meanwhile
Riley who was supposed to meet with vow
to discuss their baby has been ghosted
so he does what any crazy ex does and
breaks into her home well technically he
found the key under the mat and finds
the address to Jenny's place his rescue
mission is short-lived however and he's
taken out and beaten with a shovel but
Val's able to whack Jenny with her own
chains and is able to escape what
happens next is a crazy game of chicken
in which Jenny and vow almost collided
off course jenny has been so concerned
over the safety of the child up until
this point I guess a near fatal game of
chicken didn't cross her mind Val ends
up tied to the bed just like Paul
Sheldon in the 1990 film misery in fact
much of the film is an homage to that
both Mills take place in Colorado and
feature scenes in which the captive
protagonist is tied to a bed and hobbled
Jenny tells Val that she had to do what
she had to in order to survive referring
to the murder of her own parents would
Val be willing to do the same to murder
in order to live earlier in the film Val
has a nightmare where she's about to
stab Jenny but she
doesn't go through with it Jenny says
you don't have what it takes
but if Val is to survive and save her
baby she'll need to do just that right
before Val devises a plan to take on
Jenny she has a conversation with her
unborn child which shows how her
character has changed up until this
point whereas before Val only thought
about herself getting her body back and
not being sick she's now putting her
child first all the things you could be
how do you smile could you wear look she
is now ready to complete her character
arc tricking Jenny into thinking she
killed her own child when actually it
was just Jenny's cat and using the
element of surprise kills her
I guess we now know she has what it
takes val is rescued by the police and
gives birth shortly after there is even
a fake-out where the nurse turns into
Jenny just like how Paul Sheldon sees
any Wilkes at the end of misery val has
completed her arc turning from selfish
unhappy mother-to-be to selfless happy
mother to a beautiful daughter I guess
we'll just brush over the fact her
husband and baby daddy died thanks
everyone for watching please make sure
to LIKE and subscribe and be sure to
check out my other videos for more bat
takes follow me on twitter at things
story whitey until next time remember
daddy loves you very much